foreign
the european research area
no
[Music]
[Applause]
that's
no
uh
prime minister prime minister
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
what a good moment to be here together
and allow me to start by thanking
you antonio and the foundation
and the city of lisbon for
the famous portuguese hospitality
it's wonderful and there's a reason why
it's
famous i'm delighted to be here
indeed this is one of my first trips
since the beginning of the pandemic
and this is a fitting place to talk
about the future
i say this because i
believe the past and the present
of lisbon and portugal can be a guide
for our future
for centuries the people of portugal
have influenced europe in many many ways
intellectually culturally
politically i think
for example of the enchanting landscapes
and mountains of sintra
that inspired some of the world's
greatest greatest
minds and artists for example lord byron
or
richard strauss
i also think of the vibrant portugal of
today
you have sporting heroes
you have young tech talents
you're producing clean energy
and you have a perfect mix of tradition
on one hand
and modernity on the other hand
i think of the leading role portugal
plays in europe and the world
at the helm of the biggest european and
global institutions
and i also think of how the people of
portugal responded
with humility responsibility
and solidarity when the pandemic hit
europe i could mention for example the
online platform
called host a hero
which allowed people to give health
workers from porter to
lisbon a spare room or an apartment
so they could rest and keep their
families safe
or i could mention the historic decision
by the government
to grant temporary citizenship rights
to migrants and asylum seekers
so they could access social security and
health care
from personal stories of sacrifice
to the millions of people that
downloaded contract
the contract tracing app portugal
showed the best of it
and the best of europe and we all know
the pandemic is not over
and there's still a lot of work for all
of us
ahead of us ladies and gentlemen
lisbon the city we are in today
is a living example of renewal
and recovery the devastating
earthquake in this very spot
265 years ago
was a human tragedy it was a disaster
and it came at a time of great change
and progress
for europe a time when traditions and
institutions were being challenged
intellectual freedom was blossoming
rivalries between nations were on the
rise
the parallels to today's latest disaster
may not be perfect but history
does have a habit of rhyming
i say this because even before the
pandemic hit
europe was all go already going through
a period of profound
and rapid change from digitalization
to decarbonization to global
fragmentation
and the need for us to get back on our
feet today
and build a better way of doing things
is just
as important as it was in the 18th
century
the point is we can learn from
lisbon how to build back better
how to remodel our societies to harness
change and progress
and you see it with your own eyes when
you admire
prasa do commercial a living monument of
renewal
of course times are different and we
must do things
differently in today's world
and in this spirit i very much welcome
the preparation
and cooperation of the portuguese
recovery and resilience plan
your priorities and ambitions
mirror exactly those of next generation
eu
the european union's large recovery plan
for
reforms and investment
and i want to thank you antonio prime
minister kosta
for your support in brokering this
historic agreement last july
next generation eu allows the commission
to raise 750 billion euros
on the market today in order to invest
it
in a stronger future for tomorrow that's
our game
that's our goal this is an urgent and
unprecedented necessity
but it is for an urgent and
unprecedented situation
we need to repair our social fabric
and on this i very much look forward to
the next year's
social summit organized by the
portuguese presidency
we need to protect and we need to
modernize our single market
which brings so many benefits to the
country and all the other member states
we're dependent on it it's our strength
it's our fortune and while we do this
we need to press forward
towards a fair agreement
a digital and a resilient
economy and society i know these will be
the priorities for the portuguese
recovery and resilience plan
and they are certainly priorities
for next generation eu
and once again portugal is not only well
placed to make the most out of next
generation eu
but it can provide a blueprint for all
the others
i give you an example
next generation eu will place a strong
emphasis on reforms all over europe
and portugal has a lot of experience
in doing this from the very difficult
reforms of the past
to the more recent reforms in areas
going from
lifelong learning reforming the health
care sector
or tackling labor market segmentation
to give youth a perspective for the
future
and there's of course more to do but
what i want to say is that the
commission stands ready
to support these efforts in every way we
can
from structural funds to the recovery
plan which is next generation eu
the second part of next generation eu
next to reforms is investment
investment in the economy investment in
the society of tomorrow
and here portugal also has
a head start especially when it comes to
the twin
green and digital transition
in fact portugal is already
a digital leader in many areas
and it is catching up fast in others
every year you know better than me
lisbon hosts
80 000 of the world's most
renowned tech professionals at the web
summit
this is amazing and as every other major
event
this year's web summit will be virtual
but lisbon remains the spiritual capital
of the tech scene without any question
and the fact that so many digital nomads
come to work here in startups
and to work in tech companies not only
reflects the high
quality internet of lisbon but it also
is
because of the talent drawn here
from across the world and the quality of
training
from specialized university in braga
porto
or here in lisbon and this bodes
well for portugal it bodes well for the
european
digital decade we have ahead of us
to build on this and this is the
foundation can start on
and where portugal has a head start to
build on this
we need to invest now for example in
skills
skills and smes digitalize smes in data
make sure we have a data economy we
should use our industrial data
at the moment being eighty percent of
the industrial data we collect on an
everyday basis
are never ever used once what a waste so
let's use it together
artificial intelligence human centered
artificial intelligence
5g infrastructure and we need to ensure
that the high-speed internet of lisbon
is available
everywhere in rural areas like marvao
or mansaras everywhere
so this is an example of how
next generation eu can help build
a better world to live in
and nowhere is this
more important for portugal
europe and the world
than when it comes to our environment
portugal is at the front line
in the fight against climate change you
know it all
i don't have to tell you this country is
sadly enough used to forest fires
but it has been used to these forest
fires for years
the difference now is that the frequency
and the intensity has increased and you
know
all know that the extreme weather
situations the frequency
and the intensity has increased and this
is only the beginning of climate change
there is an urgent need to act
and the pandemic has only made that more
urgent
but it's not only an urgent need to act
there's also a huge opportunity in it
that goes with it for portugal and all
those who invest
early in the green transition of today
because if we're going to be successful
in fighting climate change
if the world will follow the european
example
portugal and europe will be at the front
line
will be the exporter of technology of
knowledge of
innovation because we will need those
new those clean technologies
so this is what the european green deal
is all about
have a different economy am a
sustainable economy a circular economy
but also be innovative and be at the
forefront
of prosperity and growth that is a
different growth
that's a growth that gives back
more to the planet than it takes away
from planet
and this european green deal is our
blueprint
for the transformation of our economy
and our society
for the good of the planet
for the good of people and
for the good of our long-term prosperity
the core ambition is for europe to be a
climate neutral continent
by 2050. this is an ambition long-term
goal that needs short-term action
now and this is why
earlier this month the commission
announced a new target for emission
reductions of at least 55
by 2030 this
goal this road map
will give certainty and direction
that investors need that entrepreneurs
need innovators need they need the
certainty
they need the clear direction here in
portugal and across europe
and now we have with next generation eu
the investment into that clear direction
and that certainty we have the plan we
have the road map
and we have the investment
from investing in high-speed train
connections for example
to building renovations
as you know forty percent of our co2
emissions are coming from buildings
so insulate them renovate them
make them more efficient the investment
is here
clean mobility hydrogen
you name it next generation
you will invest in projects that make
the biggest
difference for each country
and portugal has always
been a front runner in the transition
towards cleaner energy
you started your clean transition back
in 2005
and today more than half of portugal's
electricity needs are now met by
renewable energy so you are
a shining example that it is doable
that we can make it and this is thanks
to strong government
and private sector support
support for wind for title for
solar and other forms of renewables
next generation eu is now an opportunity
to strengthen that leadership
to invest in research to invest
in innovation that this country is so
famous for so my message is
use it use it
ladies and gentlemen this is what
next generation eu is all about
it gives that the chance to not only
repair
and recover from the crisis but to
shape a better way of living for all of
us portugal will be a strong beneficiary
of next generation eu it will help boost
the economy
an economy that had recovered
so well from the last crisis
i really acknowledge that and thanks to
the hard work
and to the sacrifice of the portuguese
people
so this progress cannot be jeopardized
but we have to build on and strengthen
it
the next generation you will create jobs
by anchoring the recovery in the green
and in the digital economy of tomorrow
in doing so we will ensure that
no one is left behind
because this transition will only happen
if it is fair
and just it must be a fair
a social and a people-first recovery
and this is why when people started
losing their jobs in the
pandemic and the economic crisis
we created the first european scheme for
short time work
we call it sure the idea is very simple
and you know it
if there are no orders and companies run
out of work
because of the paralyzed economy by the
pandemic
companies do not have to let their
workers go
they can keep it in the companies
because thanks to sure they can
continue to employ them to keep the
skills to keep the experience
to keep the knowledge in the company and
crucially to keep people in their jobs
and the thought behind it is you have
the knowledge
in your companies and the moment the
moment the economy the world economy
is picking up again you have the
capabilities to say we can take the
order
because we have the possibilities in our
companies
sure is a shield for workers for jobs
and for companies and this is
real european solidarity in action and
i'm very glad that portugal is one of
the countries that will receive
support from sure and
it reflects the need
to strengthen europe's social dimension
and protect the dignity of work
and this is why we will soon come
forward with an action plan
on the implementation of the european
pillar of social rights
and i count on the portuguese presidency
we will work strongly together in this
field it will be one of the main pillars
of your presidency i know that is
a common priority we have
ladies and gentlemen
the period we're living in is a very
difficult one
and that is no different here in
portugal as in the rest
of europe and the rest of the world the
people of this
country have shown tremendous
responsibility and resilience
in the way they have come together to
fight the virus
but like everywhere else people are
tired of this fight and they want to
move on
portugal is a country
of great explorers you have a tremendous
history in that
pioneers who never fear to venture into
the unknown
a country that has always sailed in
unchartered
waters
navigators to quote
the great luis de camares
so i can think of no better country to
guide us through the storm
and to set sail to our future
and i look forward to just doing that
with you portugal with your government
with you antonio and the portuguese
presidency
next year abrigada viva europa
[Music]
you